you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum happy Valentine's week
Ryan Liu you go down times a week yeah
thanks you have a girlfriend I'm gonna
do I don't I have to plan something you
do that's on me every year isn't it I
guess so
well I can't believe that why can't the
female be up for that
up to that do that well it's you know
it's it's nice it's nice to you know to
planned stuff but happy Valentine's to
all you guys I hope you everybody out
there has a nice evening you know as
love all you need is love all we need in
this world is love sorry I was saying
that through a belch I couldn't quite
get the batch I was like this this one
where you think we're just slowly began
to fight back tears but now is a know it
sound like the guy from shroom it's I'm
bleeding I'm dying it's been a great
couple of weeks I feel like there's more
listeners you know people are excited
about the podcast you know I'm I'm
getting more and more excited about the
podcast I think you know we're closer to
the getting ready for video we're
getting close man it's coming along yeah
it is and you've got your work cut out I
do for a couple guests I do it's gonna
be a cementing it'll be worth it yes
it's gonna be worth it you're you're you
know once we get in the groove it's
gonna be a lot easier so that's coming
up videos coming up we're excited about
that thank you for all my patrons out
there go on patreon if you have them
come out there if you you know I don't
know if you know what it is but to check
it out extra footage q and A's with me
you get to ask guests questions all
sorts of fun stuff if you go to patreon
but thank you all my patrons for their
amazing support I really mean that and
thank you to my listeners just all you
guys out there thank you for listening
it's been a crazy crazy week I I'm
getting I'm getting a colonoscopy Ryan
so I'm at that age where I have to get a
colonoscopy it was fifty and then they
moved it down to 45 and I'm 47 so you
know jess is trying to tell me cuz she
had one my assistant Jess she's like
you're gonna you're gonna do you know
you're good I'm gonna [ __ ] is that what
you're saying yeah you're gonna I mean
yeah of course I know the deal she does
know you only drink liquids for the
whole day which is gonna be tough for me
you know and then you just you evacuate
things
yes but you know I don't mind being put
to sleep but she does I know but you
they put a lot of needles in you because
they can't get a vein because you're so
dehydrated and or whatever you're
guessing I don't now [ __ ] I'm not
looking forward to it
and one of my right nuts hurt hurts I
think I did in hockey or something so
hopefully I'll be okay
thanks for asking Ryan do you work up I
did but you know it's a little tight
maybe I grew out of it are you wearing
your liked cup from high school I mean
what are you know uh everyone knows that
didn't you stop growing what your balls
keep growing is that what happens uh
yeah I don't know old guys their balls
are down to their knees so maybe that's
what happens your balls just keep
sagging like Bob Saget down there I
don't know I really don't know so anyway
I got a great show for ya this is
believe it or not this is the hundredth
episode so welcome to the hundredth
episode congratulations Ryan you've been
on probably I don't know ten of them or
more more than that yeah yeah okay uh
congratulate congratulations to you
though thank you congratulations to
everybody for we're still around we're
hanging in there where the little
caboose that could and with your help
we'll continue that thank you to all the
guests who've come on the show and you
know believe in me it's hard you know in
the beginning especially to come on
podcasting uh nobody knows this Sharon
so I try to bring you guys great guests
and at least guests it will open up and
you'll find interesting and you know I
get to the point Ryan where I'm like
well hopefully get to a certain point
where people are just like you know I
don't care who Rosie interviews I know
we'll ask some fun questions and we
might learn something that's gonna be
fun even if I don't know this person
that's what you would aspire to yeah you
don't want you know you're like oh well
he doesn't have another guy from era so
I'm not listening fu rosenbaum the thing
is if you like to an interview then you
support you keep supporting you know you
can't I can't give you everything you
love but I could try you know I'm gonna
be in Richmond Richmond Virginia on
February 28th 29th we're doing small the
nights with Tom so that's gonna be fun
also doing a stage it
I believe looking online but Jason
Mane's and I are gonna do a stage it
when I'm in Richmond
so we'll do a live show online you could
check that out and that's pretty much it
you know I'm on cammy and all that
bullcrap but hey let's talk about our
guest she's she's been in a lot of stuff
she has actually
she was in stuff like Hall Pass and um
you know her new movie with Bruce Willis
trauma center
I saw a trailer for and it looked pretty
freakin intense she's been around man
she's been around the block she works
and she's got a really good attitude I
learned a lot from her I didn't think I
would and I might say that in the
interview I mean look her up she's been
in a ton and I think her for opening up
so much and let's just get into it let's
get inside of Nicky Whalen it's my part
of you you're listening to inside of you
with my rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
when did you come to the states that 14
is a day 14 years ago so you were four
thank you
close do you do you like the States it's
okay
yeah because I get that from you not
neighborhood not in an arrogant kind of
you know Australia's better
nationalistic sort of feeling it's more
like a that's my home yeah
do you know what it's not your right if
the thing is I don't want to live back
in Australia at all that was a few
places that I would live I've been to
Australia for times I'm going again in
in June and I've been and by the way if
you want to say right now if you're
sitting at home and you want to learn an
Australian accent here's what you do
there's a couple of cities that if you
just say it
you'll automatically get like for
instance Melbourne no but you say Mount
Melbourne Adelaide a delight Adelaide
Brisbane Perth Sydney impressed it's
it's this is good yeah that's about all
I can do it's really that was very
impressive you say Melbourne you see
Melvin Melvin Melbourne yeah like
America's a male born it's not right
it's a male born even though it's spelt
like that no Ryan say Adelaide Adelaide
is it performs English so I think I do
it a little English yeah maybe so yeah
but it was a good start do you hate when
Americans do it's just really hard to
hear cuz it's like very um wrong and it
comes out wrong like it's really easy
for us to do your accent because most of
our TV growing up was American but I
could always tell when someone they slip
you guys slip in and out some some
English is what yours is that good
what's terrible though it's terrible cuz
I know some people you'll you'll be
watching a movie and there's an actress
I won't say her name I just hear these
things sometimes she's trying to settle
an accent real southern like and am I
What's Wrong panting yeah it's difficult
I think but people only notice if you're
from that region everyone else will go
like oh man she's southern or oh man
she's Australian what yes you are I try
not to it's so weird doing another
accent in a movie because you just don't
feel authentic at all so you have to get
so used to it it just feels weird I
still find it weird
well trauma center that that's out
that's out that's out now video and
demand or whatever they what they call
sea it is for two weeks and then it's on
demand Bruce Willis Tito Ortiz had to do
an American accent not see you did huh
cuz that's what I was wondering I was
like I scream and cry I could see it cuz
let you know I watched I didn't get a
chance to watch the movie forgive me
only because my grandpa passed away yes
so that's a good excuse I'm gonna use
thank curve I love you up there thank
you for that one because otherwise I'd
be an [ __ ] but by the way it seems
like a very intense role I mean you it's
just you it's you in this hospital Bruce
Willis seems like the good guy in it
these some bad cops here it's not that
but it looks pretty intense and a lot of
the screaming and yelling which all I do
though I can't I maybe is that kept
coming out Australian because when I'm
genuinely bawling my eyes out and crying
I fall back into me and then I like
bowling my leg that was Australia like
because you do you just sleepy you
trying to be as real as possible I never
thought about that think about that like
think about when you're being so sincere
and then do it in an accent it's just
could you imagine if I was doing like an
English accent I'm gonna probably do on
Babbitt if there's just like you know in
the movies you know when you we know
from like let's say I'm from England and
I'm talking like this like Gary Oldman
and I and then all of a sudden in this
scene I had it's like wait now I'm
crying and it doesn't sound real because
I've never cried like that yes you have
to practice I don't know I don't know
what you do just don't say you just
might ask people to be patient with you
until it comes out right be an actress
hard isn't it the others like I'd rather
be a [ __ ] actor
shut up Rosenbaum tired of it you uh
I almost said you've been around I
didn't mean but look I say the wrong
things a lot of times first of all we
at doing Kevin and Johnny Farley's
podcast at the Olympic improv
remember you were aghast yeah you don't
remember but I do I remember you I just
remember now by that we swear on this
I'm so sorry I just let John you can
swear I'm so sorry um yeah we did I've
forgotten about that we've forgotten no
you're not at all because I said like
see you on Twitter you were for Twitter
person then Instagram you know what I
think you have to in this day and age I
fought it for so long and then I'm like
you know I got to podcast and I got
things going on and you just have to
make people aware if you don't and no
one's gonna come see a your band no not
that they do Roxy Roxy and it was a good
crowd shutting down the thing next door
to it remember it's the rain bye-bye I
just ate there so the saving it they're
keeping and remember they're gonna shut
it down anyway meltdown even if I mean
they won't see much that was the first
time I ate there and I might have had
diarrhea I'm not sure Dyer it could have
been from anything so let me ask you
you've you've been around a long time
with your career you've been acting I
look at your credits and I'm like you've
done I mean I remember Hall Pass with
the Farrelly Brothers and I mean you're
honest even how young were you a needed
that show in Australia uh 24 25 and you
were kind of a star there are you still
a star there like a big bigger star
there than here no I don't know what
when you sort of say star in Australia
it's just like people cuz neighbours is
so big there that everybody knows it so
people will know you but no one it's not
like a stone everyone looks no one it
looks you like you're a star like
Australians are like rough around the
edges like an American Hollywood happens
like oh my god but there it's like it
gives a [ __ ] so all you did know there's
anyway like it was a very different like
sort of I've towards you and no one
really cares so I don't feel like a star
there which is my family that's yeah
that's why you like Australian men I
your grandfather was a football player
when you say football whip that out
because I know stuff when your grandpa
was a football player yeah what does
that mean because if you said in America
he was a football player so he did he
played for the Broncos
yeah so he played for a huge team he
what is football first of all it's not
Australian rule so it's only in
Australian football sport so it's very
different to soccer rugby
and American footballs completely
different soccer is called football in
England it is but in Australia footballs
football a different kind of football
what the [ __ ] is wrong in rules football
and then you have soccer and then you
have rugby three different sports
Australian rules is Australian sport and
it's huge it's like throwing the second
biggest sport in Australia and my
granddad paid for a big team it's like
American football he played four he
played four Collingwood at there cold so
he would name as the astara people
remember him something Whelan Marcus
Whelan Marcus said young Marcus well
Marcus Whelan he won this medal called
the brown lobe which is very very Brown
loaf Brownlow I love you I think I won
the award brown loaf Brown I did that
life the breath is that well that's
that's southern Indiana sometimes it
comes up but go ahead so did you know
him no I never met him he was my dad's
dad he died before I came into the world
but it's like a whole thing in our
family so that's and it's it's kind of
cool because the strain rules football
is awesome I used to do TV hosting years
ago nice to interview a lot of them and
it's just a good thing to be in the mix
with it's a lot of love around that
sport in Australia did you feel like I
mean from your from Australia so we
helped there's there's certain things
that you think of but I think of people
in England I think you know they
probably a bigger drinkers and we are I
don't know that's true yeah Ryan is it
true oh yeah is that Australia - I mean
stallions can drink they can drink I can
ask was there drinking in your family
yeah like everybody can drink and does
drink I mean us they've got all of my
dad still drinks I mean my dad's nearly
80 and he's just he's you've never met
any unless still pound in it
he's just Mike pack cigarettes a day for
50 years he's quit now cuz he's nearly
died about eight times from it but he
still drinks hard koi so old school he's
old school
Ozzy's got the tattoos little boxer does
he have no patience mm-hmm oh that stuff
he's old-school dude
how does he talk like if he said
something let's say he was like get me
the newspaper Nicky and a beer what he
said well actually we're like you for
instance if I get dressed up I'm at home
and I'm going out for dinner I walk
through he goes you're right I yeah like
that's like I'll dress you right I yeah
that seemed otherwise go why are you
dressed up looking like that going out
the house it's like what
you uh you're right I out that's how he
tell I like that phrase you're right are
ya did you get me on yeah like I'll be
on the paper the front cover of a big
paper in Australia for sporting of your
own yeah
oh you right you think you're right I
have and I'm like things does that mean
like are you mental are you sure you're
saying are you going out like that what
what are you doing it's just like it's
his way of coping with whatever I'm
doing were you difficult as a child and
were they difficult parents they was
strict parents but my parents are like a
good family I'm really lucky but they'll
strict and my dad's old-school but I had
three older brothers and an older sister
and I was the youngest and I was so
badly behaved I was really naughty what
did you do just shitty at school just
like a not a good student like bounced
around to all different schools had
problems what kind of problems like a
lot of fighting like just fighting yeah
later girls
oh yeah my dad's a fight or two like
girls wouldn't pain to me at school and
I my dad with his wife cuz your Freddie
you're a pretty girl it's pretty girl
all that sort of stuff so let me let me
give me an example you're in school it's
19 whatever it is twelve nineteen twelve
just a few years before the start of the
world girls were mean did you ever punch
a girl in the face a girl got me in a
headlock once on the last day of you
nine someone had said to me early in the
morning this girl's gonna get you at
lunchtime and she was a beefcake like
she was like hardcore and I was scared
and she was gonna they said she's gonna
crack an egg on your head at lunchtime
and I was like this is awful cracked egg
on your head somebody warned you mm-hmm
that this girl was gonna crack an egg on
your head am I getting this right this
is true and I was so scared and I was
like in my dad who would be like you
have to defend yourself you have to
fight for this so I went looking for a
weapon because like I have to this woman
he's bigger than me and she has big
friends they were all like the
basketball girls and I was just like
okay she's getting an egg are you
getting a loaf of bread what do you be
staying in the food groups are we going
something more I needed a weapon what
was the weapon I went through the cattle
and I found those
cane sticks that hold up plants you know
when you're holding up in a new tree as
it's growing and you get a kind of a
bracing it
ripped that out of the soil and I
carried it round my way no one said
anything why are you carrying a cane
sneakers day anyway came to lunchtime
and the girls come around the corner and
everyone gathered in this like area
common area it was awful
and she came over to me she goes hey
Nicky and she got her friend who's like
six-foot some basketball and hands are
like this egg and she just grabs me and
gets me in a headlock I'm like here we
go what's happening and I go down and
she just like gets the egg and rubs it
into my head and then like but you had
the egg beater and then I went my turn
and I just like whacked it with this
where she went down on her back he hit
her with a stick down and she was like
and that was there well she was in pain
and then they went I hear this
Nicky wheel into the front office place
I was like really this is not my fault I
did not stop this is pure defense well I
was the Prince like a whale Nicky it
looks like yeah you know she might have
put an egg in your head but
unfortunately ya beat her with a stick
and that's where that's a crime I got
into so much trouble that I asked I
tried to expel me and suspend me and it
was a whole thing but my dad I was so
scared when I got home right on you it's
gonna be grounded they ring this IKEA I
was upstairs in my bedroom I was and my
dad goes I hear him answer the phone and
then I hear about okay grounded for life
expelled I come downstairs and he looks
me I'm standing in the kitchen I'm
shaking I'm so scared cuz I like it was
pretty hardcore it happened and he said
to me um if anyone ever touches you I'll
give you permission to defend yourself
don't worry about it
I was like immediately you had so much
more love for your father at that moment
it's like yes I'm allowed to follow are
you close with your family like you you
tell them about you do you call them
crying about your personal problems my
mom and my sister super close no
absolutely everything
really yeah I'm really lucky cuz I don't
know a lot of people come to LA and
escaping their family and trauma I'm not
my plan B doesn't suck my plan B is go
home and live with my awesome family on
the bay boys a plan B but you've never
done it even when times get tough do you
ever just say I'm leaving I'm going
you've always stuck around
I think and I think that and you know
this you can't just because you don't
work for a couple months give up oh my
god I love now working for a couple
months so do I get to vacuum and go to
Bed Bath and Beyond and do delicious
activities are you are you someone that
when they don't work they get a little
depressed and they do you don't know you
don't worry about the next job you don't
think you know because I tend I you know
just says you know you have an addiction
to shopping you do but I don't here's
the thing as I look I want you to tell
me
and maybe my listeners can write in and
you I don't go I don't buy lavish [ __ ] I
don't go out I have a van out there
that's 17 years old I have a truck
that's eight years old a pickup I like
your check thank you I get Star Wars
toys that cost you know maybe 20 bucks
here 50 bucks here something out of
convention you see had this I don't
believe you some of these stylist stuff
is worth an absolute before should I've
had that stuff a long time so but I
don't I'm just gonna - Princess Leia
puppet up there how much is that dude
$60 really yeah like so what I'm saying
is maybe I buy stuff but here's I have a
rule if I buy Parrish sneakers I give
two away to charity or two or two would
ya always you have a little system I
have a system whenever I buy something I
get rid of something or I give to
somebody that's good
yeah but do you think that's an
addiction if I like Etsy somebody
[ __ ] introduced me to Etsy have you
been on Etsy oh yes I have they make I
always dress up as one of the jedis the
Star Wars and they make the proper
tentacles
I've been Ellis Akira and I was um for a
couple of an Etsy make the impression
ones out of the latex no I love it I
have a that start the Friday the 13th
there's a on the door had a sign made
from Etsy oh yeah Friday 13 that says
Camp Crystal Lake well I just like cool
things I don't need expensive things I
mean I wear like I'm a t-shirt kind of
cords dude cords a good really good
quality very nice look like I'm looking
at every other cords I'm looking at
cards they're good quality codes let me
ask you this to your parents
do you ever cuz you've been in
relationships you've been married was
married for a second yeah
married for second like five months and
he was a football player mm-hmm now this
football player do you think Oh
grandpa's a football player I want to
impress subconsciously I want to impress
mom and dad so I'm gonna date a football
player no I dated nine football players
that's only football that I've ever
dated and that was the first and last
ever it was so weird like left-of-center
and I didn't think of him as a
footballer because he had retired when I
met him so I didn't think he wasn't like
playing football or anything so we never
did any football stuff he watched
football but I was like oh wow I mean
look it's obviously it's a stupid
question but it's hard getting divorced
like what's the hardest part about
getting divorced other than to me it
isn't it just like dealing with the rest
of the world
not so much unless you're like really
honest it's funny when you go through
breakups and they're public people get
really really screwed up about what
other people are gonna think and I swear
to god maybe this is I have other issues
and other things that bother me but
that's the last thing I could give a
[ __ ] about is what other people think
and what they're gonna write who said
why did I get that from you
I just I guess I'm right language but
like that wasn't the thing that bothered
me and to be honest with you in my
divorce I this is the thing if I had
kids or around property with him I can
understand how things can get
complicated but you know when you fall
out of love and it's over and you never
want to see that person again and then
you would have to deal with years
they're going to court and fight for
kids that's what makes it so
traumatizing is you can't leave getting
divorced is difficult and I was like
this is the most I remember looking into
going out how do how do you get divorced
like you have to look at online online
to see how to get divorced it was like
how do you do how do people get divorce
like I don't want to get a lawyer I
don't wanna get a mediator I don't want
anything from him I'm sure he doesn't
want anything from me um Brian look up
how do you get divorced there's all
these places that like you need a lawyer
you need a mediator and I was like but I
don't want anything and he didn't want
anything well if you don't want anything
that makes it easier but when yeah I
think when people are like oh you know
what I want half I've been I think it's
fair if like you work from the ground up
from the beginning of someone's success
let's say let's say he was making a lot
of money yeah and it started with you
together so then there's a K we may
build an empire or we built or we we
have $50,000 whatever I think that
you're entitled to get half but when it
comes to before you met there was
like that I guess that's all about
pretty much nothing about any of that
like we talked about a prenup and I was
like no anything from I just there was
never that again
I run into him a couple times Sega day
like it's nice sort of like details but
it was painful it's messy it's weird at
shitty but it's also like we were done
we were done and we signed a piece of
paper and we walked out of the office
because we didn't go to a lawyer or
anything we just were like signed
paperwork and we walked out and he
walked to his Aston Martin and I walked
to my knees let me drive it more to go
he went that way and I went to my little
missin and he goes see ya and then we
just drove off and there was no like
that's my fork again there was no no no
I I just because I was done and he was
done and then there's no I don't need
anything from you like I don't want any
we both work we both make money it's
good so in my case I must say I had an
easy divorce but that's I see people go
through traumatic [ __ ] and you know a
few things were written for the three
people that know who we are but like and
again I'll just give a [ __ ] like no I
don't know there's other things that
upset me and there's other thing what
obsess you what other things there's so
many other things there's so many
unexpected things that happen lies lies
hurt cheating like cheating hurts those
are painful things but your computer
never cheated in my life you've never
cheated in your life never change I
command you you know what not gonna
would ya I mean not not gonna would but
I haven't either
not kind of what I hope I don't know I
haven't either yeah that's one thing I
can't do so that's like when I am in a
relationship when I say I love you this
is us not the NBC series but like this
is us yeah
then that's it hi I like to hear that
for me that well it's important I've
said that before Ryan are you that guy -
yeah yeah no yeah was weird I like yeah
was weird
I was just googling how to get divorced
and now I'm asking like is this short
blurb well it's just for Cal yeah
there's a short one go ahead before you
can file for divorce in California at
least one spouse must be a resident of
the state for six months or 180 days
once you've filed for divorce and
deliver the paperwork to your spouse you
must wait at least six months from the
day
your spouse received the papers before
the divorce can be finalized we got a
piece of paper six months later I was
like with some friends
and I just open my mailbox and there's a
little letter and said you are
officially divorced not exactly that but
that's what it is and I go oh there we
go did you celebrate to be honest with
you we did do some friends and there was
a sense of freedom to it and we all had
smoothies soil just did like a little
gravy the smoothies and then we got over
the day like it I don't know I like I'm
making it sound so Cavalier no but you
look I'm sure there's those moments were
you like everybody look it wasn't a big
deal and you go home sometimes and you
hear a song
oh he he touched my shoulder during and
must have the way rock says what the
lead singer to rock set died like three
days ago oh my god am I breaking this to
you how did she passed I don't know how
she passed but it did in fact I whenever
someone passes I mean a singer I always
get on my Sonos or whatever my Napster I
still have Napster and I play their hits
while I shower I listen to the time did
she die I think she died she had that
song
yeah marie Fredriksson yeah died
December 9 of this year that was two
three days ago
what does it say of what no she actually
sang the song she's got a bride a girl
turn blue or bright i boy and then she
had um join the joyride the big love
dangerous you know she's looking up guys
give a little tear and glass of wine and
figure that I'm gonna have to sit with
that after this Def Leppard's alive
still I'm gonna see them in concert ey9
drama yeah safe leopard animal greatest
song they ever wrote and the music video
at the circus I'm more of a pyromania
guy photograph Rock of Ages Fulton green
Brockton rules god I feel like we're
from the same time well probably they
are you're younger than I do you I'm 47
I'm sorry what
yeah why is he like yeah I like this
area really good
well series I am 47
oh you like close to all right now
people are gonna think you're flirting
cut it out you bloody 40 look at you oh
you do 40 drink tea smite you Patti I
mean no I don't I don't really I mean
I'll have a casual drink or I'll smoke a
little grass here and there that I say
grass think I did I don't I'm off all
pills your skin is so smooth well it's
not really a zit on my nose then I had
to put some clearest I'll touch-up
before today that's true yeah I have
this thing I got out trying to Niska
I still get six you get zits yeah why
why don't we get six run you get zits
yeah you do where do you get them all
over sometimes above your ass crack
above the ass crack sure I do that and
then you just take a loo for those are
easy to get away just loofah a little
bit boom gone
I don't ever get them I'm glad to hear
that I'm happy to hear that inside of
you is brought to you by Squarespace
make it yourself easily create a website
by yourself how many times you have to
hire people Ryan ever I have to hire
everybody for ever and I haven't what I
haven't because I use this stuff you use
Squarespace that's cuz it's easier make
it stand out with a beautiful website
that's easy you can do this you think it
you dream it you make it with
Squarespace ready to start a new
business
get started with Squarespace create a
beautiful website to turn your cool idea
into a new website showcase your work
blog or publish content sell products
services of all kinds promote your
physical or online business announce an
upcoming event or special project
there's so many things you can do and so
many people use it as it's not just you
know if you think artists well how about
furniture makers personal trainers art
galleries it's very easy with
Squarespace head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code I owe you to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
enter code I owe you inside of you is
brought to you by better help my friends
that better help well this is what we
talk about a lot on the podcast
we talk about anxiety we talk about life
being stressful and we could all use
help when we're feeling down but you
know maybe we don't know how or where to
ask for it maybe we're a little
embarrassed which we shouldn't because
we're trying to normalize this thing
here
better help is available for all of us
it's available for you better help
offers licensed counselors who
specialize in issues including
depression and anxiety also complicated
relationships family sleeping grief
stress trauma anger these are all things
a lot of us deal with and you can go to
better help online for counseling
you can connect privately with a
counselor through text chat phone and
video calls and get help on your own
time at your own pace at an affordable
rate inside of you listeners will get
10% off their first month with discount
code inside
that's better help.com slash inside as
an actor or as just a human being it
like you've modeled you've done all
these things you've been in the in the
public for a long time do you do you get
anxiety do you get have you ever do you
know what anxiety is have you ever felt
a panic attack or you've never
experienced that in my 20s severe
hardcore vertigo horrendous horrendous
anxiety what happens with vertigo
sitting there talking to you right now
and then all of a sudden I'm just like I
start spinning in the chair and I can't
everything starts spinning I had brain
scans I was like there's something wrong
with me horrendous as in my early 20s I
thought I was dying the worst panic
attack vertigo vertigo is a part of
anxiety and it feels like it because
vertigo it's very dangerous if you're
driving because you can't control it's
like I'm sitting here looking at you and
then all of a sudden everything starts
you can't focus you fall over what do
you do you just wait till it passes and
it's horrendous and how long does it how
many times is it come on they used to
come and go for years I'm sometimes I
wouldn't have for a couple months and
I'd have a hard core for a week and I
realized it's just pockets of trauma and
things that have happened through life
that I've forgotten about trying to come
out and when the old Lee started I
started doing a lot of self-help work I
meditate two hours a day I don't have
panic attacks I don't get nervous the
only time I ever get nervous
is if I'm on a first date I get really
nervous and if I am auditioning on set
out in public red carpets public
speaking could give a [ __ ] when our
first date and auditions I fall to
pieces otherwise I'm just don't care
has anyone ever came up to you and said
Olivia you look so good you look so
young still I've met someone on a photo
shoot yesterday he the photographer said
to me do you know Olivia newton-john is
this way that you just said that no but
I did meet her once oh my god I'd love
to meet her I was in her driveway at her
house my girlfriend it's hysterical my
own afraid girl by the way they call
them you get godmother and it was weird
because I daughter was there Meryl like
you look more like my mom than I do and
I was like I'll take this cuz I love
Olivia newton-john yeah who doesn't love
Olivia newton-john Jessica all right
back back to this anxiety stuff because
you know to go that's pretty traumatic
what did you find out was causing this
because you got down to the to the
surface of it or not the certain would
you say you got deep you can't sometimes
I just can't big [ __ ] all over me so
what so you started getting yourself
help you started going probably a
therapy started reading so it'll go what
is causing this and how did you get to
the root of the problem how did you how
did you know or just put it into it it's
it's a reflection of the people you date
the things that every year to look
around you and see what you're bringing
into your life what's going on at the
time how you're why you're doing the
things you do it's time and people erase
so quickly to get all these answers in a
38 I can sit here and go okay so all the
things that I've been through in my life
and why I bought that in and why I moved
to America and and growing up as a kid
and trauma through high school and you
don't have to have crazy family and be
how putting horrible circumstances to
grow up and have problems we all have
problems we all have issues even if your
parents did the greatest job you'll
still come out a little screwy
like we and some of the most evolved
kids had the most craziest parents it's
just a mixture of DNA and who you are
and you just figure it out and we all
have [ __ ] you get into relay
they tend to be this first you know the
thing that really highlights our messes
because if relationships require us to
be vulnerable and when you're vulnerable
weird [ __ ] comes out when we perform and
we're vulnerable weird [ __ ] and as you
get older you just realize we're all
we're all a bit [ __ ] and it's okay and
we're all working through it and it's
hard to change patterning from childhood
we all go I've changed and then we end
up in the same relationship or the same
job or the unemployment it's about
breaking those patterns and I found
meditation and I found some incredible
people over the years and this is the
thing I like about la the weirdest
[ __ ] people move here so you can find
the craziest shamans or the cray that
really can help you you find something
that digs in triggers your great
therapist hypnotherapy I've done it all
and I found my system and so yeah I just
stay with it yeah do you still stay with
it so you wake up Mickey wailing wakes
up what does she do first thing I take
my dog out to the bathroom and I thank
people I should have done that this
morning long and my bathrooms filled
with presents all right so go ahead so
then what do you do I make are you on
your phone at this point I've had a
quick flick at it sometimes I try not to
get too into the Instagram because then
I'll go out for coffee grab coffee make
coffee
I bring Yoda back to bed he sits between
my legs fine goes on to timer this few
sips of coffee shot my own bomb goes
into timer
I put the timer on for about an hour
depending on happen to take another
little sleep no I meditate Oh an hour
meditation
listen unemployed actors can meditate
for an hour we have no excuse if I'm
working as twenty minutes
is 20 minutes not enough if you're not
working
no it's ample I just enjoyed the process
you have guided meditation or do you
have just quiet silence and where does
your mind go to for instance like right
now we're talking and you're meditating
your eyes are closed does your mind just
race because this is the problem I think
a lot of people out there I've meditated
now it's a hundred and sixty two days
straight yeah because I you know does it
work all the time every day know it but
people think oh I can't meditate because
my mind races and that's the whole point
your mind does race you're human
so the whole point is if you can get
moments of just where your heads clear
and breathing through it and being
present right so what goes through your
mind everything oh my god what I'm gonna
do what it did today
I can sometimes I'm like this isn't
working and then other times I just drop
in there was a quote I saw recently that
I don't know if Bill Murray said it was
under a picture of Bill Murray and it
said something like I just me I just try
and show up each day and be available
for life to happen to me and that's
meditation you just lay there you sit
there whatever your processes it's not
about oh my god my mind's racing
eventually as you know it will calm down
and if it doesn't don't worry about it
you'll get it the next day he's the
discipline of stopping and doing nothing
and allowing it's like when I booked
trauma center I swear to god I was in
the bath at my sister's it was December
last year I laid in the bath it was
summertime I put my head back in oh and
I have no idea where my next paychecks
coming from I'm 37 I have no idea what
I'm doing next in my life and I honestly
went universe I'm all yours just give me
what you want like honestly whatever you
got next I trust you I swear to God and
I felt open I felt so relaxed I put my
head back and within 4 minutes my phone
started ringing it was a producer I'm
like please wants to party I'm not no I
did not are you working with Bruce
Wallace it's exactly right he takes me
goes answer the phone Whelan I mean I am
relaxing he goes read the script
shooting in Puerto Rico March you Bruce
Willis action movie tell me if you want
to do it and I just went thank you there
is something to the so I try and tell
actors and listen it's easy for me
because I shot a couple movies this year
but like I don't always do that but just
try and try and be open because as being
open is the key and and I don't allow
work to be the validation of my
happiness not give a [ __ ] right Rainn
Wilson was on here I always remember
that what he said he says I am NOT my
work yes and that's like that's hard to
sort of differentiate or sort of
separate because work is such a big part
of you but it's not you so and I haven't
been good in the last week or two
because I was really good I was waking
it like what I do is I don't touch my
phone for an hour oh yeah I you know but
sometimes I start to drift off or
sometimes I'm not eating right so it's
being good to yourself in kind of so say
hey
I [ __ ] up for a week I'm human let's
get back on it yeah let's get back on
this let's do the healthy [ __ ] again
let's go back on the hikes let's go do
this and I think a lot of people
including myself that's why I was
probably addicted to xanax for a long
time because I just felt like my mind I
can't turn my mind off and I'm not gonna
sleep and I'd rather sleep some of the
Papas annex tonight and I'll go to sleep
or you know I'm doing the lead in the
show and I can't I just
I'm gonna producer on it and I have to I
have to be great and I have to have
energy tomorrow and I'm putting so much
pressure on myself and it could it could
just take you in a very you know sort of
a downhill spiral so my thought is
everybody's listening a lot of people
are like none of this will work they're
gonna meditate in the like it didn't
work I'm going back to a pill or I'm
going back to just get discipline you
got to be dude it's all about discipline
isn't it it's all daisy-chain and
structure in your life okay some
mornings I'm rushing out a house I
always make my bed but no I make my bed
every morning now thank you mate if you
don't make your bed we're on our yeah
just yeah well that's a very good nice
shower but I just our in the morning
yeah it's just people al searching for
day once I get my next job I'm gonna be
happy [ __ ] God be happy go and be
happy with your mates whenever I've got
time off even if I haven't made a great
deal of money I'm like like I like my
life when I'm not working just as much
as when I am working if not sometimes
more I love my friends I love my family
if I'm going through a patch or I'm
going through rough then I get really
into my self-help work love your life
and then it work then the acting thing
doesn't become such a oh god I'm not
working I'm not validated it's only
gonna be better it's not like that it's
you know like you guys know you've been
on the hugest shows worked with the
biggest actors in the world it ends and
you come back to your home and you you
just you know you're doing normal [ __ ]
again it's just got us I just think
there's too much we put to being here
and every time you step out the door and
I was like what are you working on how's
life what are you doing it's not the
worst thing here you know it's like I'm
not working on anything at the moment
I'm having coffee and walking my dog
every day and partying and having some
fun and travelling I don't think people
are listening anyway when they say that
oh what you working on I don't really
care in their minds hey how are you
oh hi how are you doing some everyone
still ah I'm not great just to see if
they're listening and everyone smells
some girl why I'm just kidding to see if
you were listening you know how are you
I was super busy so busy I couldn't be
busier
I'm satellite is oh that's crazy
you know what Nikki yes say your last
name again Wheelan okay guys I said
Waylon why don't you stop me yeah this
does anybody see Nikki Waylon it
Sweetland why do I say I've always said
Weiland it was well I think Waylon
Jennings well I think of a wife I'll
call you Jennings sure you know Waylon
Jennings me Waylon Jennings I think sang
the song just a good old boys the law
what show is that anybody know well
Google machine IV everybody listen are
you [ __ ] kidding me said Dukes of
Hazzard Nicki I uh I'm gonna be honest
with you I like you a lot more than I
liked you before like I didn't really
know you
yeah met you once you were nice everyone
will see each other like oh hey I'm like
I don't know maybe yeah you know you're
in your head you're being judged it's
like oh you know she's whatever she's
nice you know nothing in common
isn't that typical of people because I'm
sitting down with you and having a real
conversation and I'm Gavin when I'm
gathering is now do we have the same
likes and passions but we're also
working on ourselves I this whole last
year has been an awakening for me has it
and so when I hear you talk about things
and I and all I could do is what you're
talking going kind of hope she's really
being honest right now because this is
this is awesome I hope she's not a liar
this is do you know what it is if you
look at our social media you look at our
lives we're all living our best lives
and it's absolute [ __ ] I'm not gonna
post me looking like [ __ ] miserable
though I like to keep things light and
fluffy because my personal life is my
personal life better I'm gonna sit down
and you're gonna ask me I want to share
pain trauma things that go down some
days nothing has to be going wrong to
have a meltdown some days just being a
human is really hard it's hard to be
alive you know should we be married
should we have kids
Hollywood weird
life in itself and then you go overseas
they don't give a [ __ ] about Hollywood
no-one's ever got Instagram and they're
suffering from their own things it's
weird we're all getting through it so I
always talk about meditation and how
important it is to not find validation
in this damn business
just get your life good get your life
really drilled of yourself I really
really really do you love yourself look
in the mirror you go Nicky Whelan no I
look in the mirror someone's had some
rough trade this morning but I look at
myself and I don't feel guilt I don't
feel feelings of shame I've worked on
all these things I really don't and
that's the beauty at being 38 you know
people leaving me alone
well 37 last year when I had this like
meltdown but now say yeah I do know it
because a good thing is no one's looking
for me to be hot 20s anymore there's no
pressure in that [ __ ] anymore I I'm
comfortable with it I don't know there's
something about as you get older your
care factor just a mine does anyway you
just it just feels better to be here I
don't know my head is better I've done a
lot of work and I still have meltdowns
and shitty days to runs like me but like
I still have hell days but I just I I
kind of like Who I am and that can be a
little lonely because when you're
letting off a very strong I'm good
it's it people get scared cuz I can't
latch on to your insecurities you can't
connect with guys because you can't get
into unhealthy [ __ ] it can be lonely
being healthy do you um like when you
date guys hmm do you like a guy who
could open up and cry in front of you
yeah as long as it's not everyday of
course I mean if you imagine oh my god
yeah you know you don't want that Ryan
do you cry yeah i crying for my
girlfriend to Amanda well movies mostly
though Oh movies do you ever just cry
and go no sorry it's just I
movies too I was on a date and I was
with my friend Rob and and a lovely lady
and we're sitting there and watching
that movie ad astra oh and nobody like I
thought they were just so engaged and
just loved it and they turned to me at
the very end I'm like how is beautiful
what the [ __ ] what's with you guys
aren't crying
and I just was like that they kind of
looked at me that they were cool about
it but I was like [ __ ] I get I get like
touched when I'm touched about something
like this girl came up to me and this
woman came up to me in England at a
convention as I'm walking into the
convention for the first time last
weekend and she just looked at me and
her eyes are filling up with tears and
she's like your podcast has really
helped me and I I you know I seem like a
crazy person right now but just like
you're talking about depression and
anxiety and family and hearing other
people's it's just you know like
instance it was like normalizing it and
I got emotional I hugged her and I'm
instead of going oh thank you thank you
so much
I actually allowed myself to [ __ ]
feel it and I'm doing that more where
I'm like this is a beautiful thing right
now I inadvertently helped someone and
fellow human being and I'm proud of that
and grateful that I could do that and we
shared a moment we shared a moment
through thee and see how I turn it in I
get vulnerable then I try to throw funny
that's a committee that's what I do so
comedians do it's good to feel but just
I think across the board we rolled this
new ear and there's equal rights and all
these great things happening involved in
all these wonderful things changing but
some mornings you got to wake up and
this might be the Ozzie and me sometimes
just gonna [ __ ] get on with it I'm
sorry I something I love to be getting
on with it I love the indulging I love
feeling I love embracing stuff but we
can as actors not having you know not
working for a couple weeks we can really
get down the rabbit hole with how we
feel some days you got to go stop I've
cried for four hours we've all had a
breakdown get hours so no days I mean
four hours longer but like you know you
get down the rabbit hole stop
we felt let's get on with it sometimes
there's something to my mom always said
she goes you know your problem is all
you in Hollywood half you aren't working
you got way too much time on your hands
get out and get busy get a job get busy
because when your brains work when
you're on a set you might be going
through something but you just you know
you do feel better and say my brains
working she cuz get busy do you love
acting or do you just do it because you
can and it makes you money but it's
something you're on set for 14 hours a
day and go this is great I love this I
love when I'm on the job I love being on
set and I love being in the job but and
I kind of don't mind the promo and
everything aside of it as well like I
kinda don't mind promoting movies I like
you know this sort of stuff I don't mind
doing all the publicity a lot of actors
don't love the publicity side of stuff
but I indulge you know you see me red
carpet that's probably why you like I
don't really know a lot of pretty
pictures of herself yeah like look at my
Instagram oh my god bikini red carpet
photo shoot sponsoring this did it I
indulge in all of it I am in the mix I
get into it I make that part of the job
a lot of a commodity you're like I'm
sure you're trying to sell yourself so
you work more and you're like relevant
right get in the mix it's just a job who
cares if some people like back no-strike
finding me and they're like really nahi
posting another picture I'm like yep
next but you know what it's this is
really cool the dichotomy of who you are
an Instagram maybe with the pictures and
who you are just for real
like you said you don't need to show
everybody who the [ __ ] you are that's
for your own private world your own
private life your friends your family
and I think that's amazing
because in a sense I do the same [ __ ]
thing yeah like I you know you're you're
naturally beauty so I don't beautiful
naturally you're naturally beauty you
know you know I'm not saying I'm not
sitting here self-deprecating I'm just
saying you know I like to do funny
videos oh here's me doing this oh here's
doing this oh my bands playing so I
promote myself yeah
I'd say I love what you're watching you
it's so funny little things I do drop
[ __ ] all the time I know what the hell's
wrong with me but there's an ad at you
see that it's an Imperial Walker up
there I see it you do dude
you're you're a big star Wars fan how
many times like every other actor did
you just call your agent go just get me
in get me an audition I'll be an extra
I'll be a stormtrooper you too small for
a store
trooper Niki funny you say that I'll be
a Jawa
there's no jobless in the next one
that's only in the Mandalorians by the
way the Mandalorian guys watch that I
have no part of it in it but it's
freaking great is it you should watch it
I'm on it I am actually there's a part
of me look if I offer me something in
Star Wars I'd be there but here's the
thing
don't you just love being able to enjoy
it mm-hmm like it's my escape it's one
of the movies you'll just have look you
just Chuck any of them on and haven't
going in the background you know this
year I was working over Halloween but
Halloween's a really big thing for me
because it's based around Star Wars
every well you were in Halloween - Rob
Zombie's movie right yeah I know she dug
deep
I didn't he didn't I just thought
honestly I you know what I do with my
guests it's funny because one person had
this note and you guys tell me tweet me
and let me know if you think they're
wrong I don't like to do a bunch of
digging I want to know something about
them and I just want to talk about
journeys and I want about what they do
and how they get through things in life
and somebody said that you know some of
your episodes are great but they're
sometimes you just you should dig deeper
in your indie or what they've done it's
people want to feel [ __ ] like that's why
reality TV works as well as it does
don't them but that's why it does
because you're seeing the ugliest
realest most shocking as things and
people want to feel something so you're
on a podcast you're gonna ask me the
trauma I've been through and why I feel
the way I feel cuz people be like mmm it
is it that other than everything's great
I'm so busy you do no offense but you
could watch and they're great shows you
could watch the late night show with any
of those guys they're all great there I
mean Kimmel is a genius they're all
brilliant but you know what you go on in
for four minutes and you talk about
lightly oh yeah great great and then you
know there's nothing it's just all
service the band plays it's fun you
don't get into this person at all here
you could have a conversation and really
get to understand someone yeah
that's why I like it and it's therapy
for me I talked about that on the flip
side of that though do you ever feel
like like I've worked with Nick Cage a
couple down three times name-dropped
three times but I'm getting to a good
you might say him sitting on a podcast
you won't have say find his Instagram or
Twitter because he doesn't have any of
it
there is a mystical magic to how
Hollywood used to be with no social
media and you'd be like you know what is
so-and-so doing behind the scenes like
you know the Jack Nicholson's of these
worlds and Meryl Streep's who don't have
all these Instagram
well I know but do you not I mean like
there's a mystical so when we come on
here as actors in our generation until
all our dirt does it take away our magic
of our business of what makes it so
magical or is it just now we're in a
place where we need to reveal so much
because the something that keeps when I
walk onto set and Nick's there or I did
a movie with Nick and Willem Dafoe was
in it and I saw Willem Dafoe knows like
there he is in the person like you can't
you can't find that man anywhere and to
be lucky enough to be on a set with him
for five minutes he's like this mystical
man and it's like because you can't find
him it is something delicious about I I
agree with you but I'm gonna always find
the what's ago yeah yeah do the devil's
advocate here didn't think of it I kept
thinking Pacino that was it I love that
but I think that someone want Leonardo
DiCaprio who is epitomizes movie stars I
mean this guy is the D movie star yeah
and what he does for the world and the
environment and when people see his
tweets and his things he posts and he's
on there but he does it mostly it's
people are listening to him I'm
listening to him yeah so when you have
an influence like Tom Hanks and he gets
them there and this is important I'm
like you know Tom's a really smart guy
like I know him Tom let me tell you Tom
but you know for me I'm not a big star
I've done some great things I was on a
hit show I have a podcast yeah I feel
like you know what I really love like
for me why I'm on it I'm not defending
it because I think you're right we're
both right maybe no one's gonna know if
I have a podcast if I don't at least
promote it yeah if I don't if people
like me and want to listen to me I have
to get out there and and put it on there
and let them know where it
is and let them know where my Dan's
playing because unlike you know the 70s
or 80s were you know you could actually
sell albums if you have a song you have
to go on tour now as a band yeah like
and we're not really a tour we go places
but we're like hey we want people to
listen to music we're proud of it
it's a smart thing to do I think if you
overdo it or you use it like there's Lee
it gets kind of in a gray area like you
talk about the conference's you have 26
million followers knowing how do these
people have to while they're doing
something they're making videos they're
whatever I don't know these people but
you know what they're doing something
right and so I'm trying to take the
whole judge thing out of it and you're
not I'm not saying you're judging yeah
but as much as I want to judge it much
like what the [ __ ] is this person like
you know what they're doing their thing
man yeah and as long as it's not dumping
[ __ ] into the world because I could
still go [ __ ] you what are you doing
yeah maybe you have 26 million people
but 26 million people are idiots yeah
that they're if they're like you're a
role model mm-hmm you know what I mean
so I don't know it gets kind of cloudy
and I just think it's important to
respect to a certain degree I just don't
think it'll ever be that way never never
but I just loved the idea that Hollywood
was always such a mystery and you would
come here and ha I spotted so-and-so at
the Beverly Hills Hotel today now it's
like yeah your influences walking down
and he's thinks he's more famous than
Robert De Niro and you're like there's
this this weird nice to our business now
and I agree get out there make it happen
sell yourself there's so many talented
people who'd never get seen now they
have platforms all of that I'm not
against it and if you've got to promote
yourself where we've lived both you know
we were around 20 years ago when things
were not so sad yes I wasn't around with
social media I was done with smallville
and because it would've been as big as
supernatural is now I don't think or at
least close it was a big show so you
know we didn't have social media so it
wasn't and I'm grateful I'm look I'm
grateful for living in the 80's 90's I'm
grateful for like borrowing my parents
VCR so I could copy John Carpenter's The
Thing in my bedroom because I was a dork
and I couldn't get a date so I'm copying
movies thinking that
if I have three movies on a VHS tape
this is gonna be worth something little
did I know it would erase in 15 years so
I love all that stuff I love saying hey
well go to the movies tonight I'll meet
you there at 8:00 and you just have to
meet and you cut through my back yard if
through jump fences dude I love it I
miss that people will never understand I
feel sorry for kids around the day it's
just like it's all about the phone it's
all about the computer and I get it I
sound like an old man and I do it too
yeah we're in the mix that's what we're
talking about like what you said you
know splitting that you know or you said
like having a life it's not just all
work it's really spending quality time
really having really having a life where
would that be family whatever it is yeah
had when you have a good life when you
can get excited about your coffee in the
morning wait for Michael genuinely
you're living a great great life is
there nothing else everything else that
comes in and listen and I'm sure there's
actors listening oh yeah but I've got to
make money and so do I I still got to
make money too you know there's this
whole thing to it but I just but you
have to really enjoy life and and and
and go on little what's the word
adventures ventures thank you activities
that's I'm - I just had a golf I just
picked up golf started playing a little
miniature I'm terrible at it I put up in
at the heating range I'm learning how to
golf I'm more Park there's a little
thing on Moorpark yeah what's it yeah
yeah yeah driving range there I've been
like I'm just giving everything a crack
it frustrates me but like I get this one
I hate it I feel so good I'm present
finding new activities at 38 it's weird
you have to do it by the way Jack
Nicholson yeah he's not on Twitter and
Instagram because he spent 75 years of
his life not on any you know they mean
Nic Cage gets huge movies he's a
billionaire so he doesn't need to
promote himself Willem Dafoe will always
work we aren't big stars so it makes
more sense to people like us to use it
as opposed to big stars I had some
friends of mine that were like eh you
just better having a go at me going
always promoting yourself I'm like
unfortunately I'm not Angelina Jolie and
I got to put myself out there and I've
got to get speed these different markets
of things
on and they was so nasty about it with
me and I was like I don't have a choice
I'm in the mix these aren't your friends
are you actually not my friends anymore
sidenote they aren't my friends anymore
but they were really weird about it with
me and I they were China I think they
were uncomfortable with how I could
promote myself because there is a gross
mistook because you remember like 10
years ago if you took a selfie like oh
my god I took a selfie they're so into
themselves over now we're like hey
they're still in that mentality of
Christ I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] you
know what all I care about is be a good
person yeah be a good person have a good
heart listen to people try to enjoy your
life and you know try to be supportive
to people you like if you like them you
like the podcast like it's really
important Nicky this has been a real
treat your movie first of all what's
your social handles so if you want to
see these beautiful pictures and see her
exploit herself like she's I'm kidding
but you said that but you know her now
so when you follow her you'll be like I
like her she's cool
Nicky Weiland over and I say KY wh ela
and not Waylon that wheelin trauma
center look for it it's got Bruce Willis
got Tito Ortiz and you loved filming it
badass crew loved it as how's Bruce cool
yes cool i sat down I was like because
it's so you know you get on set with
people like that and you're like why
should you my whole life is very weird
did you say that yeah no I didn't
actually I just went straight to Fifth
Element oh yeah sixth sense I see dead
people I wanted to know about Mila and I
wanted to know about all the behind
religion gary oldman
Carrie almonds my favorite yeah cleared
of all time he's so good better than me
I met him if you interviewed him no I
interviewed debruce about the faith alum
at the hotel Bruce seems like the kind
of guy that when you're talking to him
or when you're acting with him like you
can barely hear what he's saying his MMR
is he like so do a scene with me just
say something he's just like okay um are
you okay I don't know
and the only reason you could hear that
because I'm miked yeah but as an actor
I'd be like What did he say his line
because it's so intense I know how it's
gonna look when they when they print and
they put the picture up I know that that
any other sound trailer the sound guys
going [ __ ] with this guy's speak up
Jesus I can't guys we got to do that
again I don't hear Bruce I don't hear
Bruce you don't hear him Bruce can you
do anything and I'm like I remember
there's a Tom and I was doing a movie or
early on a micro mic I don't know if you
want to do that I just I don't really
care so and then I do regulate hey can
you speak up
I go doesn't it sound is it gonna look
better if I don't like I thought maybe
it's just gonna be better if I don't
talk louder it's a surreal moment and
they've got a damn mic on your handle
just just act cover it Nicki Whelan this
has been a really treat I really enjoyed
this um I don't know what else to say
did you have fun today I had heaps of
fun I'm obsessed with your house I feel
like I need to like poke around all
these shelves and bits and pieces your
home is absolutely beautiful
well I think you really look for a long
time and I've made it mine my own I can
stalk you now allow me to be inside of
you I just say that every break that
noise everybody yeah I say thank you for
lying to be inside of you too guys girls
it's just this the quote welcome all
right thanks guys you know I like when a
guest open up opens up I always say that
Ryan and I did I feel like she was
genuine she talked about our divorce you
think somebody's gonna act a certain way
and it's gonna be beneath them and
that's why we shouldn't judge people
because I thought she was really she was
a good guest you know I mean we worked
on your Australian a little bit yeah I
told you you know that's the key you got
to do the the we call those the cities
in Australia that's how you do it
Adelaide Adelaide Adelaide Adelaide
Brisbane Brisbane Melbourne
yep Melbourne
if Sydney something like that I mean
that's how I do it anyway that was 100th
episode so give yourselves a hand thank
you how many people you think have
listened to every episode I wonder if
there's anything is actually listened to
a hundred of them that's gonna be tough
if you are tweet me and tell me that
because I think that's pretty cool
shout out to the patrons Angelina gee
Yukiko Jill II mah Jason w Daniel B
Lauren G Robert B Nico P Jerry W Bob
good old Bob B Suzanne T Leah s Tricia F
mark a Scott beat Kevin R Abdullah a hi
Abdullah ID I'm Kay and Emily F Nancy D
Allison oh very way it's Barry L isn't
it I'm gonna say Barry L I always miss
it he's gonna hate me now is even not be
my patron anymore Raj C and Sarah V you
guys Rock I really appreciate you and
thank you all for listening and your
continued loyal loyal loyal ship what
would you say your loyalty loyalty and
what's foot ship whale ship is a new
work can we create that sure loyal ship
the name of your yacht hey man my yacht
is loyal ship again thank you so much if
you want to be a patron and contribute
more you can but thanks for subscribing
thanks for all this stuff
Ryan you got anything to plug well I
mean you can watch a recap rap I did
about the crisis on Infinite Earths
which I'm in which you are in I have a
small part you were kind enough to do
that and where can they find that you
can find that on youtube.com slash the
warp zone it's really funny he's really
talented check out how funny is you're
gonna become a fan of Ryan's and then
he's gonna leave me and that's how it
goes and then he could also see me I do
an emperor palpatine bit in the most
recent video
oh yeah Geoff fun doing that yeah I'll
show it to you there's a lot of work it
was a it was a lot of work that was
actually when I was on set when you
FaceTime me and I was getting the makeup
done you know oh yeah yeah you look
great yeah it's looks even better I was
I wasn't even totally done this [ __ ]
should do before you become famous hi
Ryan what what do you mean what if you
just did wouldn't you just be happy just
doing this for the rest of your life
probably not
you probably get tired I'm
a lot of fun right now see that's
something having so much fun trying to
go with it do you promise when you if
you do become famous which I think you
will whatever you you get some you still
do that stuff yeah still keep doing this
stuff this stuff that makes you tick
that makes you you will cuz you're good
at it
thanks man yeah dude I hope you love the
show tell us what you think right in you
know I read oh this is a somebody
emailed us here and that's hello at
inside of you
podcast.com if you want to write in
hello at inside of you podcast calm this
is from Arvind Arvind
I'm gonna go with Arvind I'm a longtime
fan of yours but a new fan of your
podcast I wanted to write to you in two
parts as a fan and a physician please
feel free to read them in whatever order
you wish well you know what let me just
read the physician part cuz that's what
it sound like wait a min I want to know
what a physician thinks of this show I
hope he says you're not a [ __ ] doctor
stop trying to help people let's see
what he says Arvind I work as a family
physician in Arizona and treat patients
with anxiety depression PTSD etc on a
daily basis the biggest challenge that I
face is to convince my patients that
their experiences are not uncommon and
can be overcome many people with mental
health feel isolated and alone as if
there was something wrong with them the
key is to empower those individuals that
there is nothing wrong with them that
cannot be fixed by what is right with
them your show does good work on that
front I especially want to commend you
and Stephen Amell for shining a light on
how it can feel to be overcome by
circumstances the culture and community
that you are helping to create a of
individuals sharing their feelings and
emotions in a way that normalizes their
experiences so that they can escape the
sensation of isolation that often
destroys individuals I wish you all the
success in the podcast because it has
the potential to be more than
transformative for more maybe that again
I wish you all the success in this
podcast because it has the potential to
be more transformative than other work
that you have done sincerely Arvind PS
if I can help as a medical resource
please feel free to contact me Arvind
that means a lot you know the goal was
just to talk to people and if they tell
these stories maybe someone listens and
goes I could relate to that and that's
really what it was it wasn't about
giving advice other than what helps you
I don't know what advice when someone
just says this is what works for me well
that's what works for them it may not
work for you but it doesn't mean you
can't be helped so thank you and thank
you all right in retweets subscribe all
that stuff tell the world share this
podcast with the world thank you for
allowing to be inside of all of you
[Music]
you